[Music]
hey guys Wes here in this video series
we're going to be doing some mobile
development using ionic so we're going
to be building a simple notetaking
application that will deploy two ionic
view so that we could actually test your
application out on stain iPhone for
instance or any other mobile device so
let's take a look
[Music]
so here's a look at the application will
be building in this series you can see
that we have an app called my notes and
on the front page of this application we
have a list of notes that we've created
in the past and you can see that we have
the ability to create a new note either
by clicking the button at the bottom of
the screen here or at the upper right
hand corner we have this icon that we
can click on to add a new note so on
this page we have the ability to supply
a date and a title and some note content
and we can actually go ahead and save
that note and we'll look at using ionic
storage to actually persist the data
that we saved to our application so once
we've created some notes here we can
click on them and then we get taken to a
sort of detail page if you will where we
have a title and the date and the note
content displayed and it's here we can
actually delete a note which will take
us back to the home page we'll also look
at how to do some basic styling so for
instance having different background
images for the different pages that we
have as well as using some of my onyx
out-of-the-box components like these
buttons and these list items and the
icons for instance towards the end of
this series we'll look at how to deploy
this application to ionic view so that
we could actually test it on say an
iPhone even though I'll be developing on
Windows throughout this series so with
that let's go ahead and get started
so the first thing that I'm going to do
is actually install ionic and Cordova
and we use NPM for that so if you don't
have n PM make sure that you have node
installed first of all which should
actually install the NPM package manager
so we'll go ahead and NPM install - JEE
ionic and I'm going to use specifically
at the time of this recording the
current version which is 3.1 9.0 and
we'll also install Cordova at 8.00 so
the reason I'm going to install a
specific version here is because of
course in the future these versions will
update and they may make breaking
changes so if you'd like to follow along
with the video then installing these
specific versions should make that a
little bit easier okay so once those are
installed we can go ahead and create a
new project using I onyx
so we're gonna say ionic start my notes
and this will just be the name of your
applications so feel free to name this
whatever you like here we're gonna have
the option to choose a starter template
and for this series I'm just going to
use a blank template which will just be
a very simple starter project and for
now we'll say no to whether or not we'd
like to integrate our new app with
Cordova and we'll also say no to whether
or not we want to install ionic pro SDK
okay with that ionic has created a new
directory for us so we can go ahead and
CD in to my notes and if we just take a
look at what's in this directory we can
see that we have a new project
scaffolded out for us so this is going
to look pretty similar to an angular
project that might be created with the
angular CLI for instance so I'm just
going to go ahead and open up visual
studio code in this directory and you
can see that we have this source
directory which contains a number of
different directories as well as our
index that HTML and a directory called
pages where we have this home directory
that has a home dot HTML page and assets
directory and an app directory so before
we dive into some code let's go ahead
and just start the application and see
what it looks like so for that we can
just use ionic serve and so you can see
that this is going to start our
development server running on port 80
100 in my case and so it should open up
a new browser window here and this is
our ion occation so throughout this
series I'm actually just going to be
using Chrome to sort of debug our
application and we'll be using the
inspector here so if you control shift I
to open that and here I will have the
device toolbar toggled so just like this
icon to toggle between sort of desktop
mode and device mode and with the device
toolbar note that you can also select a
preset device so this is kind of nice we
can see how our application would look
if we were using any number of different
type of built-in devices here ok with
that let's go ahead and take a look at
our home page so I'm in the pages
directory and then under
home we're looking at home dot html'
here and we'll just make this look a
little bit neater
okay so right off the bat we can see we
have this eye on header tag that
contains an eye on nav bar and then eye
on title where we have this ionic blank
title here let's go ahead and change
this to my notes and when we say we can
see that our server our development
server restarts and we should see my
notes in the header bar here likewise we
can change what's inside this ion
content tag so we'll just remove that
for now so now we have a completely
blank content area so if you've
developed other applications with
angular in the past the directory
structure here will look pretty familiar
so ionic has this pages directory that
will contain a directory for any number
of different angular components that we
might build so any ionic application
will consist of any number of different
pages and any one of those pages is an
angular component so you'll notice that
in the home directory if we look at the
typescript file here we can see that we
have our component directive where we
have our selector and our template URL
and then the class home page with some
default constructor that's been
scaffolded out here one thing that we
don't have here is an array containing
our Styles which you may see if you've
used the angular CLI for instance or
worked on another angular project
instead by default angular is currently
using as CSS files and we don't need to
include this in our style sheets array
here in s CSS we can actually just nest
our selectors and so any styles which go
into our page home component here will
apply to this specific component you
could of course use the sort of standard
angular style sheet array in your
component decorator but for this series
I'll just stick with using a CSS as well
okay so let's take a look at our app
module typescript file in our app
directory so here you'll see our
declarations where we'll put some the
new components that we create notice
also that in this application we have an
entry components array in our app module
file and we're also going to put any of
the pages that we'd like to visit in our
application here as well and we'll get
into this
a little bit more detail a little bit
later let's look now at our app dot HTML
file so you can see that all this
contains is an ion nav element and here
we have a reference to this root page
property which if we take a look in our
typescript file simply stores a
reference to our home page component and
so our root page here in this case our
home page will be at the bottom of a
stack of pages that we might navigate
through when we use our application so
ionic is going to use a stack to
essentially manage routing in our app so
this is different than using like URL
routes like you might use in a standard
web application in this case ionic is
going to use something called the nav
controller which will basically manage
that stack so the page at the top of the
stack will be the current page that
we're viewing and then to go to a
previous page we would simply pop the
top page off of the stack which would
cause the page under the previous top
page to be at the top and likewise if
we'd like to visit somewhere else in our
application we can simply push a page
onto the stack
causing a new page to be at the top so
ionic essentially manages all of our
navigation using this stack of pages we
always view the topmost page of a stack
and we navigate by either pushing or
popping new pages onto that stack so
let's go ahead and generate our first
new page so I'm gonna leave the server
running and just open up a new console
and here we can just use ionic generate
page and let's call this page add note
ok so we'll head back into the code and
notice that in our pages directory we
have this new directory add note so with
that created let's go ahead and check
out the HTML file and we're gonna change
add note here to simply add note and
we'll go ahead and remove some of this
generated stuff from the template
generator and then in ion content here
I'll simply say add note page so what
I'm going to do now is create a button
on our home page that we can click and
then it will take us over to our add
note page to sort of demonstrate that
routing concept that we just talked
about so let's go into home and
in home.html I'm gonna do is go ahead
and create a button here so notice that
when we use this I on button directive
we get some nice default styling for our
button so here I'm just gonna add a clip
listener and we'll just create a method
called add note so now if we go into our
home type script file we'll go ahead and
create that method and now we're going
to use this nav controller that we have
access to you that's been injected into
our constructor here to actually push
the add note page onto the top of our
navigation stack if you will so now we
just need to make sure to add a
reference to add note page and then in
our app module file we need to also go
ahead and add that to our list of
declarations and make sure it's imported
here as well and then we'll also need to
include it in our entry components so
now if we click our button you can see
we get taken to our add note page now
we're going to go ahead and create a new
service that will be used for managing
the notes in our application so this
service will be responsible for both
creating new notes as well as retrieving
them for us so that we can see them
either in a list or a detailed view and
we can just use the ionic CLI to
generate that service for us so we will
say ionic generate provider note service
and this is going to create a new
directory called providers and that will
contain our new class note service in a
subdirectory of the same name so you can
see that it's just an angular service we
have our injectable decorator here I'm
just going to go ahead and remove some
of this boilerplate and here we're going
to use ionic storage which will
essentially allow us to save key value
pairs as well as JSON data for our
application it uses a variety of
different means of storing data
including sequel Lite and local storage
so I'm going to head back to the command
line and here we'll just say ionic
cordova plugin add cordova c polite
storage
okay so let's go ahead and minimize this
and now in our notes service what I'm
going to do is go ahead and import
storage from ionic storage now we need
to head into our app module and then in
our imports right here just after the
ionic module for root we're gonna go
ahead and also import ionic storage
module for root okay and just make sure
that this gets imported as well at the
top of the file so let's head back to
our add note page so under pages add
note HTML and let's create a basic form
here so within the ion content tags I'm
going to go ahead and create a new form
and at first we're going to use a simple
template driven form so first of all
we'll say on submit here what we'll do
is we'll call some method add note in
our component and it will store a local
reference to the form here which we'll
set to ng form and this will give us a
reference to the form that we're
currently using and then we can pass
effed-up value to this method in our
component so this be the simple example
first
so we'll just write it out really
quickly here so first we'll create a new
Island item using this eye on item
attribute likewise we can use eye on
label to create a label for our forum
which we'll just call title and then we
can use eye on text area with the name
of title okay now for this simple
example here first we'll be using a
template driven approach so we use ng
model here to get a reference to the
title property here in our component
that we can then use and then just below
the item here we'll have our button ion
button and here we'll just say save note
so now we'll have access to this object
that has a title from our form based on
whatever we type into our text area so
let's go ahead and select add note and
you can see that we have our text field
and then
save note here so what I'm going to do
is head into our add note type script
file and again we'll remove some of this
boilerplate and you can see that we have
a sort of lifecycle hook method that
gets called here which currently is just
logging something to the console when
the ionic view loads so we're gonna go
ahead and just remove that as well and
we're going to create our add note
method in our add note type script file
and in fact I think I'd like to call
this save note so let's go ahead and
rename this to save note and then back
in our typescript file here we have our
save note function and what we're gonna
do is pass it this value which will be
an object that has a title property on
it which is a of type string and so now
we'd like to actually make use of our
notes service so we'll go ahead and
inject that into this constructor so
we'll call it a note service and it will
be a type note service and we can go
ahead and make that import here as well
okay and right and so it looks like it
can't resolve our note service saying
that it has no exported member note
service so let's go take a look here
okay so it's calling it note service
provider I think I'd like just to call
it note service so we'll change the name
here and then in our app module we'll
also need to make sure that the name
that we import here is is also note
service we'll head down into our
providers and should just have one note
service okay so I'm gonna go ahead and
close some of these open tabs and then
in our add note type script file we now
have a valid import of our notes service
and we've injected it into our
constructor here so now let's go ahead
and invoke it so we'll call this notes
service and here we'll have a save note
method
that will pass value which in this case
is currently just the title of the note
that we're going to create so let's go
ahead and create this method in our
notes service so I'm just going to f12
on note service and we'll remove what's
in our constructor and we'll go ahead
and create this method save note it's
obviously going to take the value of our
note title so we'll make the input
parameter note which will be of a type
object that has a title on it which is a
string and then what we need to do is
essentially push this note that we want
to save on to an array of these notes
and for now let's just do a really
simple way of doing that where we'll
actually just store a reference to those
notes in this service so I'm going to go
ahead and above the constructor create a
private notes property which will be
basically an array of objects that
contain a title of type string and we
can even initialize that just as an
empty array here and then you can see
all we need to do now is to actually
push on to that array of notes so we
have a way to save our notes and now we
also need a way to of course retrieve
them so let's create a method get all
notes and here all we need to do is
actually return this notes in fact maybe
here we'll just return a copy of this
notes which we can do using the spread
operator this would also be like if we
wanted to use slice instead of the
spread operator so in a sense we're just
returning a copy of this notes and not
returning sort of a pointer to it
directly but in any case we can use a
spread operator or slice for that
okay so then back in our ad note
component we've now completed our method
to save the note which should call the
same note function in our note service
adding it to that array of notes that
it's collecting and now maybe on our
home page
age so if we look in the home type
script file we'll use the note service
to get all the notes and then display
them out here so again we'll inject any
private note service here type notes for
this and we'll go ahead and make that
import and so just after our add note
method that we created we can create one
called get all notes and here we'll
return all notes from our notes service
so we can call this note service dot get
all notes that will return again a copy
of that array of notes that is stored in
the note service and then we'll have an
analogous array of notes in this
component so we can have notes which
again will be an array of this object
that contains a total property which is
a type string and we'll initialize it as
it into your a and now we can use one of
ionics lifecycle hooks here I on view
will enter and we can set the stat notes
to the stack yet all notes so I on view
will enter is just a life cycle event
this one runs when a page is about to
enter and become the active page there
are a number of different life cycle
events that we can make use of including
on viewdidload and if you did enter
among others including when we when
we're about to leave a page for instance
if you'd like to see a full list of
other lifecycle events then be sure to
check out the ionic docs and you can
find these under life cycle events under
nav controller ok and then back in our
notes service I'm going to go ahead and
just remove what's in our constructor
here so we don't actually need anything
in our constructor here yet okay so the
last thing we need to do here is to
actually create the part of our template
that will allow us to display the notes
that we're saving on the home page here
so I'm gonna go to the home dot HTML
template page and then here just above
our button what I'm gonna do is create a
new ion list so you can see the number
of different components that addict
it's out of the box which are really
useful and here will create any button
we'll use the eye on item directive here
to provide some styling and now we can
use a standard ng for star energy for
here to loop through our array of notes
so we can just say let note of notes and
then we can use some interpolation here
to just go ahead and grab the title from
each of those notes which was the only
property that we have on it anyway at
the moment okay so this is just pretty
standard angular here so this notes in
our let note of notes is referring to
the notes property that we have in our
component and when this view is about to
enter we call our get all notes method
which invokes our note service to return
a copy of all the notes that it's
storing let's go ahead and test it out
so we'll create a new note caught first
note and then we'll go ahead and try to
save it okay so we don't get any sort of
feedback but if we click back now we can
see that we have the first note in our
list so we can go ahead and add a second
note and we can save that and then we go
back and we can see that second note is
also in our list okay so what I'm going
to do now is inside of our source
directory I'm going to create a new
subdirectory and we'll just call that
models and we're gonna use this
directory to store a model for our note
objects let's go ahead and create a new
file it's gonna be a new type script
file and we're just gonna call it note
that model that TS it's just gonna
contain a simple interface export so
we'll go ahead and export interface note
and now we can define the different
properties that any note in our app will
have let's keep it simple we'll have a
title which will be a string we'll have
some content which will hold the note
content which would be a string then
we'll have a date so we'll allow the
user to select a date and then I'm going
to have this property create date which
would be a number and we'll take a look
at how we're going to use this a little
bit later but we're essentially going to
use it to be a way to get a sort of
unique identifier for any note that gets
created and it's going to be represented
as an
number because when we create a new date
we are going to essentially represent
that in milliseconds since I believe
January 1st 1970 so we'll take a look at
how that's used in a little while okay
so what I want to do now is to implement
ionic storage so let's head back into
our providers directory and then into
our notes service so if you recall
previously we imported storage from
annexed orage that we haven't
implemented it yet so previously we were
simply pushing a new object onto this
notes array any time we were saving it
using this method we don't really get
any data persistence so as soon as we
get a new instance of our notes service
we get an empty array of our notes and
so that essentially has the effect of
deleting any of the notes that we've
stored there anytime our application
restarts so we're gonna use ionic
storage to do some basic data
persistence now and we're lucky in that
with ionic storage it's actually pretty
easy to get data persistence setup so
let's take a look the first thing that I
like to do is to remove these objects
that we've used as sort of placeholders
for our note object and now we can
actually bring in the new note interface
that we had defined and so we'll go
ahead and import that from our models
directory so now our notes property will
just be a collection or an array of this
note object if you will and likewise
when we save a note here we can also
make it of type note okay so this should
really change the functionality yet we
just have this new object type which has
several different properties on it so
anytime we save a note what I'm going to
do is first thing that I'm gonna do is
simply set that create date that we
talked about just a moment ago as a new
date dot now returning a number which as
I mentioned will basically just be the
number of milliseconds since January 1st
1970 UTC and so we should get a new
number at least for our purposes any
time we create a new note here
we wanted to scale our app and perhaps
make this a little bit more robust and
we might find a different way to get a
unique identifier here but as I
mentioned this should serve our purposes
so we're still gonna push a note on to
our array but now what we'll do is we'll
say this that's storage and we need to
actually bring in or inject a storage
service if you will into our constructor
of type storage again this is coming
from ionic storage and so this that
storage has some methods on it including
a set method and so as you can see from
a little intellisense I got there this
is going to basically set a value for a
given key
so we're gonna have a sort of like
dictionary type structure where we have
key value pairs and that we can set an
access with storage so we'll make a key
notes and we can set any other sort of
object here so let's just go ahead and
set our notes array to that notes key
okay so now how are we going to get all
notes well let's look at how we can get
notes from storage so if for instance if
our app were to refresh and we were to
get this that notes then we would just
simply get an empty array if nothing had
yet been pushed on to that array so what
we'll do instead here is we'll return
and then we'll use this debt storage and
now we'll use a method get that we have
here and you can see that this is just
to get the value associated with a given
key so we have a sort of getter and a
setter method here and now we just pass
it that key and this is going to return
it promise so we can call then on it to
pass it a callback function to do
something when this promise gets
resolved so let's just call that notes
and what we want to do here is first of
all we want to handle the initial case
when notes is null so let's just do it
this way we're gonna set this debt notes
equal
two notes should get returned from our
callback function but when that's null
then we are going to set it to empty
array otherwise return us notes so we
have a sort of ternary operator here
where we want to check whether or not
notes that we're getting back from local
storage is null if that's the case then
return an empty array otherwise return
the notes we should get back from local
storage and so we set that to this that
notes that is on our class here and then
what we can do is once again simply
return a copy of them here so use a
spread operator inside of square
brackets here to return a copy of this
as an array so as we saw previously you
could also just return this that notes
that slice as well to return a copy so
that part yeah I'll just leave up to you
okay cool so now you can see that that's
actually super easy to simply get some
data persistence set up using ionic
storage and ionic storage is going to be
handling all of the you know the storage
aspect of keeping this data persisted in
the background and so it will be using
things like local storage or sequel
light or web sequel things like that to
provide us with that data persistence
also if you missed it in the previous
video you will want to double-check your
app tap module type script file in the
app directory and ensure that you've
brought ensure that you've imported
ionic storage module from ionic storage
and included it among your imports and
called for root on it here okay so while
we're in here what I'm gonna do is go
ahead and make another import for some
forms so we can import
forms module
as well as reactive forms module from
angular slash forbs okay and we're going
to use the forms module and the reactive
forms module to improve the form that we
have currently in use in our app so
we're going to come down here and in our
imports array we need to actually make
sure that we bring those in so the forms
module and reactive forms module if you
don't import these modules then you'll
get some kind of strange errors when we
update our forms okay so that should
take care of our imports for the time
being now I'd like to head back to our
add note page so you can f12 there if
you're using visual studio code and if
you haven't removed the scaffolded code
here in the placeholder code we can
remove that as well okay so what I want
to do now is to head back to our add
note page that we briefly build up in
the previous video and you'll notice now
that we should also implement our note
object rather than use this sort of in
place object that we were calling value
before when we are saving a note so I'm
going to make this a type note and we'll
actually call the brand that we pass it
a note and so we'll need to make sure
that we bring that in as well so I'll
control period here and bring it in from
our models directory and
we will just go ahead and update the
brand here as well okay so far so good
the other thing I'm going to do is
remove nav params from our constructor
here so if you have that in your
constructor we can go ahead and remove
it and really all that we need in this
class anyway is a nav controller and a
note service injected so and all we have
currently is the save note method which
will invoke save note from our injected
instance of a note service here and we
are going to save some sort of note
object so we'll need a way to actually
pass that note object from our form to
our component here so that it can then
be passed to our note service so we'll
take a look at what is in the template
so let's head over there and so you can
see that previously we built this sort
of template driven form where when we
submit that form we pass the forms value
and whatever it contains here to our
component and you can see we have this
text area with a name title and that was
all we were actually passing back with
the ng-model binding so we had some
property title with an NG model
directive on it and so we're going to
update our form here from being a very
simple to a template based form to a
more model based and reactive form so
let's take a look at that now so first
of all we're going to use two new sort
of directives here we're going to use
form group the sort of an input which
will be an input and we'll set that to
form group we're still going to bind to
ng submit event here and rather than
call add note on the component and
passing it the value on our forum in
fact we can go ahead and remove the
reference to the form itself and we can
pass this form group objects value up so
this form group is going to contain a
number of different form controls in
fact just one form control for each of
the different fields that we'd like to
pass
from our forum back up to the component
so let's take our title for instance
here and I'm going to change this ion
text area to an ion input which is what
it should have been to begin with so
we've got an ion input for our title
here now and I'm gonna remove this
ng-model directive our ion input will
still have a name title I'm also going
to give it a type of text but now we're
going to use this form control name and
we're going to set that to title this is
going to allow us to bind to a title
property in our component but this title
property will be a sort of child if you
will of this form group as a whole okay
now we can do some sort of reactive
stuff here which is pretty cool what
we're gonna do is make a div class alert
and we're gonna ng-if and say if the
form is not valid or if this field is
not valid then we're gonna cause this
alert div to show so we can say if the
form group controls and we can access
title here so you can see that our form
control is title and so form group has
this controls collection on it that we
can access using the form control name
of title here and then we can simply say
dot valid to check if this particular
form control is valid something else
kind of neat we can do here is we might
say if it's not valid and it's been
touched so in other words it's not going
to be valid when the form first loads
because it'll be empty it's required but
if it's been touched and it's not valid
and I got to pass the phone control name
here again oops and we should put this
in double quotes so if it's been touched
and it's not valid then we'll show some
alert and we can just bind that to some
property
so title alert I'm gonna just put this
on two separate lines that's little bit
easier to read okay so we've got this
div and where you're going to show it
using an NG if the title form control is
not valid and the form control has been
touched and then we're just going to
show title alert here which we can
define in our component okay so I think
that's pretty cool and relatively clean
anyway I'm gonna go ahead and just copy
the I on item and make a second one here
for the note content so it would say
maybe note here and the name will be
content as will the form control name
okay so if the content is not valid and
it's been touched and we can show some
content alert okay finally we're gonna
copy one more ion item and I'm gonna put
it above here's the first item in our
form and we're just gonna use this to
provide a little date selector and so
what we'll do here is I'm going to go
ahead and actually just remove the alert
and the input and we can actually say
ion date time and then supply a display
format here so do you month oops
a and year and then we can also give
this a form control name as we should
eight so that we can pass that up to our
component and this would be really nice
we'll see in just a moment that this
will provide us with a clean date
selector for our app okay so one more
thing we can do since we have access to
this form Group object now is on our
button we can make our button actually
disabled if the form group as a whole is
not valid so we can say form group dot
valid so our save note button will then
become enabled when the form group as a
whole is valid okay so I think that
looks good let's head back into the
component now and take care of handling
this new form it's not going to be all
that difficult
to get it wired up first of all will
have a reference to our form group which
would be of type form group and we'll
just need to make sure that we bring
form group in from manual forms and
while we're at it let's go ahead and
bring in validators and form control
okay
then let's create a property to hold our
submitted form will call that note of
type note and that will be the same note
that we will have a date which will be a
new date for its default value and then
we'll have a title which would be a
string which we can set the empty string
and content string again we'll set that
to empty string as well so we've got our
constructor and what we're going to do
inside the constructor when we have a
new instance of this class is set the
stop form group equal to a new form
group and we can just simply define it
as an object of these types here so
let's go ahead and do that so we have a
new form group and the properties on it
will be title which is a new form
control content which is a new form
control and date so we have our three
fields that we looked at in the template
we have a title content and date and we
have our save note method so let's
double check back in the template here
and resubmit add note yeah we want this
to say save note that's okay you can
call it post note or add note or save
note as I have here just want to make
sure that that calls the correct method
in the component and then one more thing
that we're going to add here is if you
recall from the previous video when we
saved a note we didn't really get any
feedback and we had to click back in our
application and go to the home page
we're simply going to use the nav
controller now to pop the current view
off of the stack if you recall from you
the first or second video and we talked
a little bit about how ionic is
specifically the nav controller is
managing
our navigation to the app it's managing
it as a stack so if we pop the current
view off of that stack we go to the
previous view which in this case should
be the home page so we save a note we
will invoke our note service to save it
to storage and then we'll pop the
current view off which should take us
back to the home page okay so speaking
of the home page we should head back
there and take a look at the component
and as you can see we need to go ahead
and use that new note interface that we
built sort of model for our note and go
ahead and reference that import here so
we can import that from models note down
model okay and you can see that it's
gonna be upset now because if you recall
when we use get all notes this is going
to return a promise of a note array
because we're using ionic storage now so
there's a couple different things we
could do here what I'm gonna do is
actually make notes a promise of note
array type and that's going to satisfy
this method but now we're getting a
promise of notes back and not a an array
of notes and so we need a way to handle
that we could call it that then on get
all notes within which we could create a
call back function and then set notes
equal to the return but what I'd like to
do instead is head over into our
template and when we are using this for
loop where we say let note of notes what
I'd like to do is to use the async pipe
here so we can type async and what this
is going to do is simply return the
result of that promise as it's available
directly in the template here so you can
use the async pipe with observables or
promises and it's really nice in the
case of observables because it will
actually handle unsubscribing from that
observable to prevent memory leaks which
is something that you would consider
doing otherwise in the component so it's
nice to be able to do this in the
template
okay so that looks good when we click
our ad note button
we'll get taken to our ad note page and
sorry about this but I see some typos
here as well so obviously we don't need
to end our double quotes here so just be
sure and your ng if your start in G if
directives here that they start with
double quotes and end with double quotes
and they wrap the boolean expression so
I think that looks okay and now let's go
ahead and fire up the server and take a
look so it's not running already we can
just ionic serve and if you have been
running the server then you may want to
consider restarting because we've
updated our dot module file okay so you
can see we have our application here we
can click add note and we have our three
fields so we can go ahead and set a date
with the date picker that's kind of nice
and we can supply some title it's a
grocery list and and we can go ahead and
save this note so we can see it here go
ahead and add a new note and we'll go
ahead and save that and so we can see
our second note here and in fact if we
refresh the application now we can see
that these notes are persisting and that
is thanks to ionic storage so if you
need to clear out your local storage and
you're using Chrome that in the
inspector you can head over to the
application tab at least at the time of
this recording I believe this used to be
under a separate tab but I don't
remember the name if you're using a
previous version of Chrome but in any
case you can see the various local
storage that chrome has here we've got
web sequel and under that you can see
actually underscore attic storage here
so you can see all of our note data here
under the notes key again with the value
just being an array of these objects
which happened to map directly to the
note interface that we created in our
app so if you want to clear any of this
out what you can do is simply click this
clear storage you can actually see how
much is being used and just be sure that
everything in your storage is selected
and then clear all site
and that's simply going to remove local
storage for this particular domain and
my case is localhost at port 80 100 so
we were if we refresh now then we will
lose our data but that was simply
because we cleared our storage from
local storage you also may get some
weird things going on if you don't clear
local storage and you make certain
changes to your app you may see some
unexpected behavior keep in mind that
you just have this simple key value pair
that's set up under web sequel in the
ionic storage sort of database here
which is currently empty because we just
emptied it but yeah you're going to want
to prevent some collisions there if you
have the same key and then you all
sudden you have brand new data so I just
like to go ahead and clear out all of
this local storage
anytime I makes or major development
changes to the app okay so we're almost
wrapped up with our ionic app now what
I'd like to do is just to make some
aesthetic changes as well as the ability
to select a note and then get taken to a
note detail page if you will so let's go
ahead and if the functionality of the
note detail page worked out first and
then we'll worry about making the app
look a little bit nicer so I'm gonna go
ahead and stop the server if it's still
running for you just go ahead and stop
it and what we're gonna do is I on
accelerate page view - note so you can
see the okay response here and then it
generated this new page for us let's go
ahead and take a look we can see it
under our pages we have this view note
directory which contains our template
and our component as well as our s CSS
file let's go ahead and hammer out the
template since it should be pretty
straightforward go ahead in as usual
remove the boilerplate code and in our
ion content I'm going to use an eye on
card element here and the eye on card
will have
card contents this is just a nice
component that ionic provides for us to
display some data and here we'll have a
on Cottard title this is gonna give us a
sort of material design type card
component to work with and here we'll
we're going to have access to a note
object in this view so let's go ahead
and grab the title property off of that
note object and then maybe just below it
will have a div with class no date and
we will grab the date just using
interpolation here again alright then
I'm just gonna keep things kind of
simple we're gonna have a separator
there and then we'll have a div that
just contains the note content okay
that's all good and then maybe at the
bottom of our view here we can have an
ion footer this is going to put a sort
of div if you will at the very bottom of
our view and in here we'll have a button
I on button and with Anik we can specify
a color and danger we'll make it a sort
of red color we'll make it block which
will make the button spread across the
entire bottom of our view and we'll have
a click event here to actually delete a
note so we want the ability to delete
notes as well as to create them and what
we're going to do is pass our unique
identifier in the form of create date
here to a click event so we'll just go
ahead and bind that delete note method
to a click event on this button and then
we can say delete note okay so that's
going to take care of a very simple note
detail page if you will that will call
view note and so let's head into the
component to kind of wire things up
again I'm going to remove the
boilerplate and we're going to inject a
note service instance into our
constructor of type note service
go ahead and bring that in and we're
going to create a new method on the node
service to handle that delete but first
we're going to need to get a note so
let's go ahead and create a property
note and whoops I need to bring in our
note model as well and we're gonna say
this set note is equal to this nav
params dot get note and the way this is
going to work we'll see here in just a
moment we're actually going to pass a
note to this view and the way that we
access that object is by calling nav
prams get and it's going to be a note
object so we are going to set the note
object in this class to that object that
we retrieve using note params okay I'm
not going to worry about this lifecycle
hook but we will have a delete note
method which will take this create date
and then we're going to pass it as we
saw in our template which is a number
type because if you recall from the last
video when we create any new note
I just knew up a new date and that will
be essentially the number of
milliseconds since January 1st 1970 UTC
so represented as a number and so will
invoke our note service here and will
write a new method on it call a delete
note and we will find that once again
using this create date as our unique
identifier after that's done we can just
simply use the nav control as we've seen
previously to pop this view on the stack
because the nav controller is managing
our routing as a stack so we'll pop this
view note page from the top of the stack
which should reveal the next view in the
stack which would be our home page okay
so let's head over into our note service
and implement this delete note
functionality so we're gonna head there
with f12 and then under get all notes
I'm gonna create that delete node method
and it's going to take our create date
which is a number and so let's think
about this for a minute because it's not
immediately obvious how we're
going to delete a single note given the
fact that when we're using storage here
we're basically updating a single key
that contains an array of notes as its
values so the key in our local storage
is notes and we've got this note array
as its value so the way that we're going
to delete a specific note given its
unique identifier is not of course to
delete the notes array but rather to
return that notes array as it is except
for the note that we want to delete so
let's do that so we know we're going to
set this that notes and we're going to
save this that notes is equal to itself
but then we're going to use filter and
we'll pass it a callback that will
basically say return where the create
date on a given note is not equal to a
create date that we pass our method and
then once that's called then we can once
again set that in storage so if we were
to have many other methods here than we
might refactor since we're using this
line repeatedly here where we're just
setting this notes key to the stat notes
but it's fine here as well but again
notice what we're doing is we're not in
a sense deleting if you will
but rather we're using filter to return
that notes array with all of its
elements except for the one that
contains the create date for the note
that we want to remove so I think this
is kind of a nice example of using
filter when we're working with an array
of objects that we want to mutate in
some way okay so that's all good but now
how are we actually going to get to our
view note page well we're going to want
to get a note from the home page so that
we can display its data all of its data
on this view note page so I'm going to
add one more method to our notes service
here and we'll call that get note
and we're gonna pass it a createdate
could be a number again recall it this
is our unique identifier for a given
note so here we're going to use the stat
storage again and we're going to get
obviously we need to get a note from our
collection of notes so we'll start with
getting that collection using the key
and this is going to return a promise so
we'll write a couple right then and then
we'll write a callback function here so
that when it resolves we can do
something with that promise so what
we're looking for is a single note so
what I'm going to do is create a private
note property which is of type noon and
so we're getting that collection notes
from storage as a promise and so when it
resolves we're going to set this dot
note equal to all of those notes for
getting back or rather a copy of them
that we can get using the spread
operator again and now we can use that
find to find a note by it's created so
create a is equal to the create date
that we pass this method and then we'll
return this note so similar to how we
use filter previously to return a
collection of notes save for the note
that were deleting that we looked up if
you will by the it's create date when we
use find we can explicitly return a
single instance of a note from an array
by looking for a create date that
matches on any one of those notes and
then simply returning it so now we have
a way for our service to return a note
given its unique identifier to any other
component that is requesting it and
where might we want to request that well
we want to request it on our home page
where we have a list of notes so we want
to be able to click on a note and when
we click on it we want to get taken to
our view note page and if you recall our
view note page that we were just working
with has a way to receive a note object
from some
params so let's wire this up now so on
our home page template what I want to do
is just add a simple click event binding
so click to some method called get note
and of course we have the note so we can
just grab its create date okay cool so
let's write this method in our component
so under add note maybe we'll write a
get note method takes a create date just
a type number and we'll invoke our note
service and specifically use the new get
new method that we just wrote passed at
the create date that we're passing in
from the template and recall this is
going to return us a promise so then
what we'll do is we'll simply say when
that resolves we set this dot note
because our promise will return that
note object that it's finding from our
array and so we can go ahead and create
a no property here I'm just gonna
explicitly make these private ok so now
when this promise resolves we set our
note and now that we have the note we
can actually use our nav controller
again to do something pretty cool which
is to actually push the view note page
so bring that in so that of course will
bring up the view note page but the view
note pages constructor is expecting us
or you know has the ability to receive
some object so as a second parameter to
push here we can add any nav params that
we want to pass along to the view so
we're going to pass this object we're
gonna call it note and we're going to
set it equal to this dot note
so what's neat about this is we're just
passing some object to the view we've
got a note property on it we set it
equal to this note that we've retrieved
from our service and then back in our
view note component in the constructor
we can see that we are going to
immediately set this note on this page
to some some nav params that we're
passing this view specifically the note
from that object that we're passing so
this is kind of a neat way I think to
pass data between pages in ionic simply
using Napa Rams and the nav controller
so if we've wired this up correctly we
should be able to now see it if we start
the server back up okay so let's take a
look we'll go ahead and add a note and
now if we click it we see that no
component factory found for view no page
did you add it to ng module about entry
components and no we did not so let's go
ahead and do that now so I forget to do
this often as I've been working with
ionic because it's not something that we
typically do if we're using just a plain
angular project using the angular CLI
but take a look in at that module about
TS and note that we have some entry
components in an array here and we need
to add any pages that ionic is going to
need to render into these entry
components which will include all the
pages for our application so let's go
ahead and include that here so if you
note page go ahead and make sure it's
imported
likewise we'll add it to our
declarations so at least at the time of
this recording the ionic CLI is not
adding view note or it's not adding new
pages that we generate to our
declarations or entry components array
okay so let's see if that has solved our
issue I'm going to go ahead and stop the
server and restart okay notice that when
you restart you should still see what's
in your local storage unless there's
something kind of wonky going on with
your local storage in any case now when
we click on our note we get taken to
this page and so that's pretty cool we
also have our delete note button so if
we delete it let's see if this is
working it appears to be working because
our note no longer exists so let's add a
couple of test notes here
and we should be able to click on a note
and yeah we can see it that's pretty
cool we can click on another note and we
can see some different data so let's see
what happens when we delete a note and
we can see that the new net that we had
just created disappears okay so now what
I want to do with a basic functionality
of our app more or less complete yes
let's go ahead and just apply some very
basic styling to the app and just kind
of clean it up a little bit before we
deploy it using ionic view so I'm gonna
just minimize this and now we can even
just stop the server and what I'm gonna
do is close out a bunch of these windows
and what I'm gonna do now is take a look
in our assets directory so we have in
our assets directory this images folder
which currently just contains an ionic
logo in there so what I'm gonna do is
drop some background images here into
this directory and this website just
provides a bunch of free stock photos
that are really high-quality so they're
kind of nice for use in building sort of
test applications or demo applications
I'm not affiliated with these guys in
any way I just figured I would give you
a heads up that this is what I use a lot
of times and yeah I find it to be really
easy to find some good photos here let's
find some background images all right
that one looks good and it's gonna
download like a medium size this one
looks good will download this one and
then I don't know maybe eat something
like this looks good
okay so the grad sent images I'm just
going to drop them here into the images
directory and I've just renamed them to
like BG one BG 2 & BG 3 alright so those
look good now what we can do is in any
one of our style sheets so let's take a
look so like in home we'll go into our
home s CSS file and I'm just going to
paste in some Styles here so you can see
that we can sort of nest our selectors
here which is kind of nice so we can see
that in this ion content div that we'll
have in our home page component
I'll just have a background and need to
fix that so it's going to be in assets /
images and then we'll have this BG want
a peg you can provide a relative path in
your URL and so that should work
likewise on our add note page if we go
into the a CSS file there I'm just going
to go ahead and paste we'll grab our
second background image and then finally
in view note I'm going to go ahead and
paste and you can see that here we'll
use our BG 3 jpg so again just use
whatever images that you've collected
and named in your assets / images
directory this other stuff here is
basically just applying a little bit of
a gradient overlay to each of the images
this is an effect that you may have seen
before where we have a sort of semi
transparent or semi
and that's going to get overlaid on this
background image I also have some CSS
class selectors here just to do a little
bit of styling to some of the other
elements on this page okay so let's go
take a look I'm gonna go ahead and start
the server okay
we'll inspect to get more of a device
type view and so you can see there's our
background it's pretty cool if we add a
note we can see another page with
another background and if we view a note
again we have a third background with a
little bit more styling on our page here
so this is pretty nifty
we might add some more things to sort of
like maybe add the date to our
collection of notes here and you could
do that very easily for instance if we
just head back to the home page it's
really up to you but maybe you have some
span here that contains the note date
for instance and so you can see it here
and then you could just style it however
you like maybe we move it back here and
I think the name of our class was just
date so there's just a little bit more
styling you can do and you can just play
around with this and get it to a place
where you're happy with it okay so now
we've sort of completed a demo version
of our application there's certainly
other things you could do here maybe you
have the ability to edit a note or copy
a note or maybe even like text a note or
something like that there's lots of
things that we could do from here but we
have a basic crud application setup or
at least create read and destroy so like
I said you may want to you create a
method to edit a note on a page that
shouldn't be too difficult we've looked
at ways to access a note directly using
the unique identifiers that we've chosen
here and so you may want to consider
adding a method to your note service to
say update a note and you could again
get that note just by using this create
date that we're using as you
fire so I'll leave that up to you to
make improvements to the app make
updates or add new features for now
let's go ahead and see how we can
actually deploy this app to a device
using ionic view so at the time of this
recording if you head over to ionic
framework comm / Pro / view you can get
some information here about view
basically a way to yeah as you can see
here share test and click feedback on
your apps and this basically allows you
to do that without ever going through
the App Store's
so not sure exactly how it's working but
basically you would download view on to
your device and it serves as almost like
a container for your application so I
have an iPhone and I simply downloaded
the new view app or the newer view app
note that there is a legacy ionic view
which I believe has a white icon but the
most up-to-date view app again at the
time of this recording has an icon with
a blue background so if you're following
along here go ahead and get the current
view app if you're using an iPhone or
Android here and then go ahead and sign
up and note that this is all free at
least just for creating a small app here
to test out on your own device so I'm
going to go ahead and login to my
account here and you can see that I've
previously deployed an app so just to
start fresh here I'm going to go ahead
and delete this app and we'll go ahead
and create a new one we'll give it a
name I just got caught mine it's again
call yours whatever you like we'll go
ahead and create it and then it's just
going to give you some very
straightforward instructions to build
and deploy your application so what we
want to do is connect an existing app
and this is going to be very similar to
using other sort of platforms as a
service so if you're using like say
Heroku or something to deploy an
application and this is going to look
very similar basically you're gonna push
a git repo containing your ionic code to
ionic and it's going to take care of
building your application and deploying
it then on your device you can log into
your account
and access that application and then
launch it directly from ionic for you
so let's go ahead and just do that let
me go ahead and stop the server and so
we're in our project directory we want
to make sure that we have the latest
ionic CLI okay so at the time of my
recording I've got ionic 3.1 9.0 and
then we'll go ahead and ionic link and
then you pass your pro ID to link the
current app to your ionic account and
then we can go ahead and get push ionic
master here okay and I forgot my
password a few times but luckily on the
third time we got it ok once that's done
we should be able to refresh the page
here and you can see the branch that you
have here along with the latest commit
so if we click here we can actually see
the build log which is pretty cool you
can even package a build for iOS or
Android which will require you to
upgrade to a pro account and you can do
some versioning here for iOS or Android
so it's pretty cool if we click head
back to our account here you can see now
that we have an app associated with our
account called my notes and so if you
have the ionic view app on your device
you can go ahead and log into your
account and then deploy this application
for testing to your device